là où ça bouge nous sommes à saint lô
pour les rendez vous soniques avec
thomas dutronc fait
on a tourné vraiment avec la musique de
l'album jusque jusqu'au mois d'août est
là maintenant on a monté un autre
spectacle qui est plus acoustique et
plus qui ressemble plus à ce que je
faisais au début ce que j'avais envie
aussi de que pierre blanchard qui joue
du violon avec nous reviennent un petit
peu avec nous donc j'avais envie de
faire un concert comme ça sans batterie
avec pierre qui est un virtuose du
violon qui virtuo fin la bande de
copains quand vos débuts avec plus de
plus de gags de surprise de sa plus
qu'une interprétation de l'album
mythique parce que tant qu'à faire
l'album on peut l'écouter il est il
existe et sur scène on propose une autre
expérience en bas de chez toi
bien cette lumière
hymne était là
non le
ce
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de me
droguer musicalement ce que maintenant
ma santé ne me permet plus de me droguer
des toutous courjault josé rodiguez
grâce à mes musiciens vous êtes à la
télé c'est bon ça vous pouvez ne pas ne
pas le répéter que je vous disais nous
aller sur scène par exemple on boit un
verre de vin un moment mais c'est pas du
tout c'est juste du 6 et du vin des
cellules voilà c'est le problème trouve
où les conseillers impératifs de la
taupe raconte travail et voilà mais il
lui - car du brouillard
ce soir je
hasard de mon coeur
tu nous aider
tous les
minet méga voleur va quitter thomas
dutronc ici même à saint lô pour
retrouver mathieu bellingen pour une
exposition du côté d'argentan
bienvenue dans le monde étrange de
benjamin lacombe dessinateur
illustrateur inventeur de monde
cela permet de voyager en fait à travers
plusieurs univers plusieurs techniques
et c'est ce que j'ai voulu mettre en
relief avec cette exposition c'est à
dire la diversité de matériaux et de
choses qu'on peut utiliser pour raconter
des histoires
benjamin lacombe a déjà 35 albums à son
actif ps j'avais fait avec olivia ruiz
quand il raconte son métier il transmet
l'envi de dessiner des histoires pour la
décennie
ce qui me plaît dans ses rencontres avec
les enfants c'est les réactions déjà
comment ils réagissent au livre comment
ils réagissent aux histoires ce qu'ils y
voit et c'est toujours intéressant
lorsqu'on est on peut découvrir soi-même
plein de choses sur nous sur nos lives
l'univers de benjamin lacombe à la
médiathèque d'argentan
c'est jusqu'au 7 janvier
une petite question pour terminer demain
soir à la luciole il ya arnaud est ce
que c'est quelqu'un que vous
affectionnez un petit bon peut-être pour
lancer son concert comme ça aussi c'est
de m'asseoir mais je le connaissais un
peu papa bien non je sais qui je les
croisais dans une boîte de nuit on était
tous il ya très longtemps fin voilà mais
dans ce que je sais qu'il a repris une
chanson de mon père la fille du père
noël un moment et sont bien son côté
rock puis son côté belge évidemment
j'adore j'adore son côté belge mais
qu'est ce que je vous dise maintenant à
savoir si vous aviez vous le connaissiez
c'est tout mais on va entre artistes on
se déteste tous et on va quand même
l'annoncé
si vous le voulez bien merci beaucoup de
bas
bonne nouvelle il reste des places pour
le concert d'arno demain soir la luciole
c'est à alençon et c'est à 21h
thalys qu est en concert demain au bbc à
hérouville à 20 heures enfin pour les
fans de reggae le groupe bana king se
produira au cargö à caen jeudi à 20 ans